son vin est encore servi aux tables des
plus grands restaurants aussi bien en
Touraine qu'ailleurs Jacky Blot
vigneront de Montlouis-sur-Loire est
décédé d'un cancer foudroyant hier à
l'âge de 75 ans il avait racheté le
domaine de la Taille aux Loups dans les
années 80 et était parvenu avec son fils
a obtenu en 2016 5 étoiles au Guide des
Vins béthan et de Sauve ce classement
parmi les meilleurs crus de France
Clémence Dausque
ancien courtier en vain arrivé à la fin
des années 80 en Touraine Jacky Blot
était convaincu du potentiel des vins de
Loire c'est entre le fleuve et son
affluent le Cher qui l'a acheté le
domaine de la taille ou loup à Montlouis
après avoir sublimé les chenins il s'est
diversifié a ouvert avec sa femme Joël
les belles caves et son bistrot il fait
partie de ses jambes ça peut être dans
l'art ça peut être dans la cuisine à
savoir qu'ils font avancer le débat
justement en ouvrant des perspectives
nouvelles en élargissant le spectre qui
est à sortir un petit peu des canons
habituels de la tradition il s'est
ouvert des portes de grands noms de la
restauration française il était présent
dans des restaurants prestigieux alors
que d'autres conduites peut-être n'y
étaient pas parce qu'il avait il avait
installé ce style et cette cette
particularité Jacky blood n'était pas
issue d'une famille de vignerons mais a
su se hisser parmi les plus grands son
travail acharné de la vigne lui a permis
d'atteindre son seul objectif
l'excellence des personnes comme Jacky
blues
il nous en manque il est vraiment moteur
dans la dynamique dans
le monde du vent c'était quelqu'un qui
avait une idée du vin qui le souhaitait
produire surtout en termes de qualité
donc qui est là tout mis en œuvre sur
son domaine pour obtenir des résultats
qualitatifs
mais aussi homme de culture il
partageait cette passion avec ses
proches et entretenez ses amitiés des
amis désormais gardiens de son souvenir
les moments qu'on passait avec Jacky
blue était pas des moments ordinaires
c'était toujours des moments d'exception
j'ai gardé j'ai gardé celle-ci un
château rayasse qu'il avait amené un
jour à la fonderie que nous avons
partagé et j'ai gardé la bouteille parce
que parce que à chaque fois que je vois
la bouteille j'ai une pensée pour lui
son fils Jean-Philippe l'avait rejoint
il y a une dizaine d'années à la tête de
ces domaines situés à Montlouis Vouvray
et Bourgueil le nom de Jacky Blot
restera intimement lié à l'histoire de
la renommée des vins de Loire